questions Secretary General prime
minister Carlos welcome back to Nato
it's great to have you here we are only
two weeks from the NATO Summit in Venus
where we'll take four reaching decisions
to bolster all the tenants and defense
and step up our support for Ukraine
the Mutiny by Wagner mercenaries at the
weekend is an internal matter for Russia
at the same time it demonstrates once
again that Preston Putin's illegal war
in Ukraine is a big strategic mistake
it has deepened existing divisions and
created new tensions in Russia
but we should not underestimate Russia
we must continue to support Ukraine and
we must keep our defenses strong
to send a clear message to Moscow and
Minsk that NATO protect every inch of
Allied territory
since 2014 we have significantly
reinforced our presence and redness from
the Black Sea to the Baltic Sea
including in Estonia
led by the United Kingdom helps to deter
any aggression
just last month exercise springstorm
demonstrated our ability to reinforce
our presence in Estonia up to Brigade
size level
fighter jets and air defenses from
allies also help to protect Estonian
skies and allies have agreed a new
rotational model for air and missile
defense allowing for Swift transition
from Air policing to air defense
at the summit we will take the next
steps with new Regional plans assigned
forces and capabilities an enhanced
exercise program
all backed by over 300 000 troops on
high redness
support for Ukraine is another top
priority for the summit
I welcome estonia's leading role in
providing critical Aid and rallying the
International Community behind the
Ukrainian people
we need to step up even more at the
summit we will agree a multi-year
package of assistance and upgrade our
political ties with Ukraine this will
being bring Ukraine closer to its
rightful place in NATO
we also need to invest more in our
security at the summit I expect we will
agree on a more ambitious defense
investment pledge with two percent of
GDP as the floor not the ceiling here
too estonia's leading by example
investing more than two percent of GDP
in defense
the villner summit will be the first
with Finland as a member and we're
working
to finalize Sweden's accession as well
therefore I have called another meeting
of senior officials from Turkey Sweden
and Finland next Thursday
the time is now to welcome Sweden as a
full member of NATO
let me finally mention Kosovo which was
also addressed in our meeting
our k for Mission continues to fulfill
its U.N mandate in partially we call on
both parties to refrain from anything
that can further ask the tensions and
return immediately to the EU facilitated
dialogue which is the only way forward
so prime minister Carlos once again
welcome to Nato it's great to have you
here and I appreciate very much your
leadership thank you so much thank you
darians the Secretary General dear
journalists
um as you know we had a very very good
discussion and I'm I'm really pleased to
be here in NATO headquarters today we
are living through turbulent times and I
really thank you Jens for having a
principal stance and building uh Allied
Unity throughout these difficult times
it is increasingly clear right now that
Ukraine is winning this war with the
help of transatlantic family right
behind it and it is clear that the
sooner Putin gets that it's losing this
war the faster Russia will return to
Russia it is our joint responsibility to
prove him by our continued support to
Ukraine and our unity and decision
making
um we also discussed preparations for
the NATO's Village Summit first the
permanent piece in Europe can only be
possible when we end the gray zones in
the security of Europe gray zones are a
breeding ground for instability and Wars
it is experience of my own country that
NATO's membership is the safest cheapest
and the most credible way of deterring
Russia Russia is a great aggression
against Ukraine has also proved this
point very clearly the only thing that
can end the cycle of aggressions against
its neighbors is NATO membership hence
for peace we need Ukraine in nato in
Bucharest Summit allies agreed that
Ukraine would become a member they
should not remain a hollow promise what
we need now is to define a practical
path to meet this goal and we need to
send a strong message of Hope to the
Ukrainian soldiers in the trenches that
with NATO membership on the horizon they
are fighting their last war with Russia
and second
we made historic decisions in Madrid
Summit these were truly significant
changes in the policy and also in the
mindset now we need to put these
decisions in practice all allies need to
continue to invest in security this will
make our transatlantic Bond even
stronger by the time allies convene in
Washington to celebrate this NATO 75th
Anniversary next summer we Europeans
must also demonstrate the Strategic leap
not only in thinking but also in real
deliverables
for that the defense of the NATO's
European allies needs a truly decisive
lift we need to step up combat
Effectiveness and we need deterrence
credible enough to avoid the war and
stop Russia's cycle of regressions for
that we need to increase defense
investment spendings for credible
deterrence and defense it is key to
close existing gaps in our capabilities
and also in our stockpiles our long-term
aim should be 2.5 percent of GDP I know
from experience how difficult it is for
a democratically elected leaders to
argue for increasing costs on defense in
Estonia we are increasing the defense
expenditure to three percent of our GDP
and that requires raising taxes and I
can tell you it's not popular
but the time matters and sending out
right signals also matters
just to give you an example from my own
country's history in 1933 at the defense
budget increased lacked political
support in Estonia in 1939 the tenfold
boost of Defense Investments was already
too late none of the equipment made it
to the time to defend Us in the second
world war and from the occupation that
followed
um third
Russia has tried to Blackmail NATO away
from its neighborhood the outcome has
been the opposite
Finland joined the alliance and I hope
Sweden will be joining as well
so in conclusion
it is a long war that Russia is fighting
it will not be over until Russia accepts
and respects Ukraine's statehood
developments within Russia should not
blur our focus and resolve aggression
must end in defeat and long-term
European security requires Ukrainian
membership in NATO we have to work on
the wording how to get there for peace
that lasts we also need accountability I
know that this is not the NATO's topic
but I I really want to stress this we
need the accountability for the crime of
aggression for Russia's leadership
without the accountability Russia's
cycle of aggression Russia cycle of
constantly attacking its neighbors will
just continue and will never stop thank
you
we'll take a few questions Estonian
public broadcaster in the middle yeah
for an opportunity
to ask two questions from both of you
um my name is Jordan Park from Estonian
public broadcasting the first question
is if those new Regional defense plans
make sure that realistically the Allied
territory is defendant in case of
conflict from the first meter from day
Zero until the victory against any enemy
and the second question is if Latvia and
Lithuania should be fortified in the
light of the presence of Wagner troops
in Belarus thank you
first of all we have to
understand that NATO already has plans
and capabilities in place to defend
every Ally and every Allied territory
and then we are further strengthening
other terms and events partly about the
decision we made in Madrid and then the
implementation and the follow-up that
will happen now in vilnews and this is
about a signing specific forces to
Pacific territories and also to increase
redness of our forces the main purpose
of this is actually not to fight the war
but to prevent the war and the Terence
has worked for more than 75 years or for
almost 75 years for this Alliance since
we were founded in 1949 and um and and
therefore this is partly a question of
forward presence we have increased our
presence also in the Baltic region but
also about high redness the ability to
quickly reinforce and a prepositioned
equipment and then we have to remember
that the the the capabilities we can
move most quickly is air and Naval
forces which is also part of the
deterrence in the in the Baltic region
so yes we are constantly assessing uh
the the the need for uh presence of
ground troops
across the whole Alliance including in
the Baltic region but I think it's
extremely important to understand that
our ability to defend every inch is also
about our ability to reinforce I have a
credible deterrence and that's exactly
what NATO is about and that will be also
demonstrated uh in in Vilnius
then on on the Warner forces well I
think it's too early to draw the any
final conclusion so what kind of
consequences that will have uh the
Mutiny the events we saw are internal
Russian matters
then uh maybe some of or we are
following and monitoring what's going on
very closely and we have seen that some
of these forces may be deployed to uh to
to Belarus but again I think it's early
to draw on any final conclusions the
most important thing is that
we are sending a very clear message to
any potential adversary including Moscow
and Minsk that we are there to protect
and defend every inch of Allied
territory against any threat so we have
increased our presence we will further
strengthen our the turns and events that
they will Summit and then we'll continue
to monitor exactly what happens with the
volume forces
as it was addressed for me as well uh
the defense plans uh I think they're
they're good we also need to make work
in in practice and that that is what we
are doing uh that the combat Readiness
of the troops is is really not a word on
the paper but actually in real life and
that actually requires the defense
Investments of all the Allies to
increase as well to be ready to fulfill
the the warehouses regarding ammunition
the
equipment necessary but I'm
I'm also uh I agree uh what was said
that uh
Alliance is ready to defend every inch
of its territory what comes to Belarus
we have considered Belarus as a go
aggressor in this war so nothing has
changed in this regard we know that
Belarus as Russia is unpredictable and
it's dangerous and this hasn't changed
so uh clearly our stance our forward
defense stance hasn't changed in this
regard as well I think we are also ready
for for any development Delphi
thank you
[Music]
hello is from Delphi in Estonia question
to both of you to both of you about the
pathway to membership for Ukraine I've
been speaking to some officials and it
seems that rather than getting a pathway
to membership in millionista
this will be decided upon later in
Washington so what is the most positive
scenario that is realistic for Ukraine
in Vilnius and what would an actual
pathway look like
but also first of all I think it's too
early and to um
pre-announce the outcome of the winner
Summit there are ongoing consultations
as they always be when we have important
decisions to make
but I'm absolutely confident that at the
winner Summit allies will find Common
Ground also on how to address Ukraine's
membership aspirations and we have to
remember that allies actually agree on a
very important messages and and
positions regarding Ukraine and
membership of NATO we all agree that
NATO store is open we have demonstrated
that reasonably by inviting Finland and
and Sweden we all agree that Ukraine
will become a member of this Alliance
and and we all agree in that it's for
the NATO allies and and and Ukraine to
decide when the time is right to invite
Ukraine to be a member of the alliance
but perhaps the most important thing we
agree on is that is that the most urgent
task now is to ensure that Ukraine
prevails as a serving independent nation
in Europe because if President Putin
wins this war then there is no more
membership issue to be discussed at all
so the the main focus should be how to
ensure that Ukraine prevails and that's
the precondition for any meaningful
discussion about further membership let
me add one more thing we are going to
strengthen our practical support uh
which will bring
Ukraine closer to Nato a multi-air
program for uh making Ukraine fully
interoperable with NATO forces it's an
important step and we're also discussing
how to further strengthen their
political ties including by
uh potentially agreeing NATO Ukraine
Council
uh yes I have uh not much to add we have
to work on the wording so that every
everybody is on board and the worries
that some allies have regarding further
steps and and also uh the hope that we
should give to ukrainians as I'm really
confident that any Gray Zone uh in in
Europe is a source of conflict and War
and actually the only security guarantee
that really works is NATO and I can tell
this by my own country's history the
reason we are not living through some
really dark times right now is because
we are in NATO and that is important and
that is also important for uh for the
prosperity of European uh continent
because if you don't have wars you have
Investments you have Economic Security
so it is in our interest that we find
this pathway but but the wording is
still being working out and don't want
to
somehow spoil the surprise of them in
the summit
last but not least Deutsche
Chevella thank you um I wanted to drill
down on my colleague's question on
Military Mobility uh prime minister
Carlos you said famously almost exactly
a year ago that you feared the Baltic
states could be overrun and that it
would take NATO 180 days to kick out
whoever's forces who might be
overrunning you are you convinced that
military Mobility has moved forward now
not just that you have stockpiles
somewhere else but that you could get
them to a crisis spot fast enough
those are part of the regional plans
um and Secretary General stoltenberg are
you disappointed at the budgeting that
the EU has given this project it was
slashed to practically nothing it was
going to be a big flag Flagship
cooperation project for nato in the EU
and do you think you could get the
forces there fast enough has turkey
agreed to these Regional plans now so
that Mobility thank you my colleagues
are nodding so we all want the answer
these answers
um is military Mobility really going to
take a big step at filmius thanks
yes this is a big issue first of all we
have moved from the deterrence posture
to defense posture which means that we
are not in in a way of you know
Conquering the territor's back or
liberating the territories afterwards
but we are ready to defend the
territories from the first minute and
the first centimeter and what of course
there's room for
um
some development regarding the military
Mobility but what I want to stress now
is that we have Finland and NATO that
changes the whole picture because
because of the military Mobility not
only making us as a peninsula in terms
of NATO but actually uh being in the
middle so so uh the help could come from
from different ways so so I'm I'm pretty
sure that we have moved from the
situation where we were a year ago by
the good decisions that we made in
Madrid and also the execution of those
plans and and now going further with uh
with those plans as well so uh of course
there is room for uh development we have
to do more but it is still much better
the situation
NATO has over the last years since 2014
implemented the biggest reinforcement to
our Collective defense in a generation
an important part of that has been and
continues to be military Mobility
because to be able to reinforce quickly
is a critical part of the way we are
providing deterrents and the way we can
reinforce and and deter any aggression
against any NATO Ally so what has
happened over the last series is really
a significant roles Improvement on
Military Mobility there has been a huge
investment in infrastructure in military
transport and logistic capacity more
pre-positioned supplies and and
equipment and and also of course we are
working very closely with the European
Union I will meet actually the European
Union will be in the European Council
tomorrow together with Kaya and all the
other e-leaders and Military Mobility
has been part of this cooperation but
this is not only depend on the budgets
of the European Union this is very much
financed by the national budgets for
investments in in military capabilities
to ensure Mobility but also in civilian
infrastructure which is important to
ensure military Mobility then this is
something we not only do in words but
also in Deeds we have the party groups
we are actually now exercising they're
able to scale them quickly up to Brigade
size levels I returned from Estonia this
week where we had a big exercise
demonstrating exactly that we had
earlier exercise in the stone not to
scale up the the British bat group and
an important part of that is to exercise
and demonstrate military Mobility to get
these forces quickly in to the
territories the countries we want them
to be
then I totally agree with prime minister
Carlos that the fact that Finland is now
a full-fledged member of the alliance
also changes the whole security
geography in the Baltic Sea region
because if you look at the map that has
profound consequences for our ability to
reinforce move forces quickly into the
Baltic region and soon Sweden also will
be a member that would further
strengthen our ability and and make it
easier to move and to reinforce forces
if if needed we'll continue to work with
the European Union but again
the the main task of NATO is not to re
to liberate land the main task of NATO
is to prevent any attack on any NATO
Ally and that and this is deterrence and
it has worked for almost 75 years we
were able to deter aggression against
West Berlin we didn't have any forces in
West Berlin in the middle of East
Germany but the Terence was credible I'm
coming from a country Norway the
northern part of nowhere didn't have any
uh other NATO troops at all about the
border with Russia the turns worked so
this is part about forward presence but
it's also about exercising demonstrating
the ability to reinforce in a credible
way to prevent any attack at all thank
you very much we will agree the regional
plans I'm absolutely
thank you very much
press conference